Hello Dr Peterson,
so I've been listening back to all of
these biblical lectures for the second
time now and um,
I wanted to show you an observation I
came upon because I was trying to find a
question that you haven't been asked
before,
which is harder than doing my ryerson
exams,
that's for sure.
So,
so I've noticed,
I think you're getting funnier.
Oh yes.
Oh No.
I think Michael Koren said that this
week I think,
but the word he used was bizarre.
I think
actually I'm feeling better,
so that's.
I actually have a sense of humor.
It's hard to believe that,
but.
So it sort of comes back when I'm not
feeling like I'm going to die at any
moment.
So I basically noticed one,
you're making more attempts a jokes,
so that's great.
Okay,
thank you.
Those jokes are landing more often,
but then there's this third element
which I think was what Steve Martin quit
because of,
which is that I think the audience is
anticipating jokes more and they're
actually,
you know,
I've noticed people laughing more at
things that aren't intending to be
jokes.
So I was just wondering what you make of
that and um,
their intended.
I'm hoping they're intended.
Just because I keep a straight face
doesn't mean they're not intended to be
jokes.
So.
Yeah.
No,
it's good.
Look,
one of the things is like,
it's,
and I've tried to keep this,
I learned a while ago probably about it
five years ago,
and even when you're dealing with really
serious matters that if you're not
handling it with a light touch,
you're not an expert at it.
You're not a master at it.
And you'd think while there are some
things that are so deep and dark that
you can't handle it with a light touch.
And that's actually not true.
You can.
That doesn't mean you make light of
them.
It doesn't mean anything like that.
It's that you don't,
it's minimal necessary force,
something like that.
You don't hit it any harder than you
have to.
And it's a,
it's an art when you're discussing
serious matters.
And so,
well,
one of the upshots of that is that
because we're discussing serious matters
and because serious matters are being
discussed in the ultra at large right
now,
it would be really good if everybody
could keep their sense of humor,
you know,
and I see positive signs of that.
Like there's a lot of satirical activity
on the net,
you know,
and that could easily categorize into
horror mob.
But it isn't,
it is,
it is.
That's happening to some degree,
but a lot of it's satire and comedy and
as long as we can keep a sense of humor
about this,
then I think,
well we're not as close to disaster as
we might be.
And so what?
One of the things that I have found
rather ominous is that there are
comedians,
first of all,
being persecuted for under free speech
restriction legislation,
which I think is absolutely appalling.
But also that there are comedians now
who won't perform on university
campuses.
John won't
Seinfeld as like,
well,
you know how offensive he is.
It's no wonder that.
I mean he's like the straightest nicest
comedian you could possibly imagine.
He won't perform on college campuses,
I think Louis Ck won't perform or or
anywhere else,
but it's a bad sign.
But no humor.
Humors is good and it's interesting
because I've been kind of watching how
I'm represented on the web weirdly
enough and there's all these memes that
have emerged,
I don't know,
thousands of the bloody things and most
of them are comical and that's good.
Like people are,
are,
they're there,
whatever it is that they're doing.
I don't know what the hell it is,
but it's being done with a relatively
light touch and that's really,
really good.
That's how it should be.
You got to have a sense of humor.
I mean,
it's one of the things that makes life
bearable so,
or maybe even better than bearable.
So.